Vsauce!
Kevin here.
High-heeled shoes were invented by Persian
horse riders to help hold their feet in stirrups,
which allowed them to stand up to shoot their
bows and arrows.
Nobility in Western Europe adopted the style
as a symbol of machismo, and the higher the
heels you wore, the wealthier you appeared
because they were so impractical for walking
on cobbled streets.
In the 1670s, the diminutive King Louis XIV
loved how high heels made him taller, and
he ordered that only members of his court
could don his trademark red heels.
Women began to adopt masculine fashion, including
the high heel, but by the 1740s men’s fashion
became more practical and less ostentatious
and high heels were considered foolish.
It wasn’t until the mid-19th century that
high heels on women symbolized female sexuality,
largely due to their use in pornographic postcards.
While neckties date back to at least 210 BC
China - they were worn by the statues of Qin
Shih Huang’s 'Terracotta Army' - there’s
no evidence to suggest that neckties were
commonly worn by men at that time.
The modern necktie evolved from the cravat
worn by 17th century Croatian soldiers, with
theories on their use being to hide a dirty
shirt, to provide psychological protection
of the neck during battle, to hold together
their jackets, or to distinguish themselves
from other soldiers.
During the Thirty Years War in the early 1600s,
Croatian mercenaries were hired by France's
King Louis XIII, and Parisians loved their
colorful knotted neckerchiefs - with the word
cravat coming from a corrupt French pronunciation
of Croate.
By the early 19th century, the way a man knotted
his neckwear became such an important indication
of his style that the cravat became known
more simply as a tie.
And it served to separate class, as you can’t
wear one while operating machinery and it
gets in the way of manual labor.
The necktie is also a phallic symbol that
points directly to a man’s…
Codpiece - a triangular cloth covering a man’s
groin, primarily worn in 15th and 16th century
Europe.
Men’s hose at that time were open at the
crotch with a doublet, a tight-fitting jacket
extending to the hips, as the only thing between
the world and their manhood.
As doublets became fashionably shorter, the
codpiece was needed to cover the area, but
it eventually evolved from simple concealment
to fanciful embellishment with King Henry
VIII of England famously sporting a massive
codpiece.
Not only did it emphasize his regal bits,
but it may have also held medicine to relieve
symptoms associated with syphilis.
The codpiece craze came to a close when Queen
Elizabeth I dictated that men’s fashion
become more feminized.
By the end of her reign in 1603, it was replaced
by a vertical opening concealed in folds of
material that evolved into something today
you may refer to as a fly.
And as always - thanks for watching!